today on the matt wall show we know that
children's hospitals across the country
are drugging and mutilating kids and now
we're starting to see the lengths
they'll go to cover up this fact also
lizzo wins big at the vmas and uses the
opportunity to complain about her
oppression the geniuses in los angeles
have invented a new way to destroy their
city require expensive hotels to house
the homeless apple tv has a new show
coming out that will make you beg for
the sweet release of death heterosexuals
march for straight pride in california
and a tick tocker explains why
frolicking in the rain is you guessed it
racist all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've heard me talk a lot on this show
about how the left is coming for your
kids through the public school system
through mainstream kids content and so
many other ways as a parent you may be
doing everything you can to protect your
child from the left's not so secret
agenda but if you don't have a will in
place designating who will take over as
parental guardian should something
happen to you then the state will
intervene if you're watching this show
i'll wager a bet that you don't want the
state making those decisions for you
which is why you need to check out epic
will epic will is an online wheel
platform that costs less than your next
trip to the store they can set you up
with a will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 plus you can save
10 percent when you go to epicwheel.com
and use code walsh a will does so much
more than protect your assets it gives
you the power to say to say who will
raise your kids should something happen
to you it allows you to appoint a health
care and financial power of attorney um
a living will slash advance directive
allows you to predetermine big decisions
concerning life support so your loved
ones won't have to you know carry that
burden of deciding take five minutes
tonight to write a will ensuring that
your kids will be raised the way you've
intended in the event that something
should happen if you go to epicwhale.com
use my code walsh today to save 10 today
well the good news is that the bad guys
are up against the ropes they're bruised
they're exposed they're nervous they're
desperate they're flailing they're
losing the bad news is that they own
everything and they set the rules
everywhere and they have most of the
power but no soul to go along with it
and so they can do almost anything and
are willing to do literally anything to
punish those who oppose them and win
back whatever ground they've lost this
is the volatile situation we find
ourselves in and here's the latest from
that front so last week we played for
you the audio obtained by shia reichik
who's the woman who runs the libsy
tiktok account
when she called the children's national
hospital in dc posing as a mother
inquiring about obtaining a gender
affirming hysterectomy quote unquote for
her 16 year old daughter now she was
told in no uncertain terms that the
hospital will in fact perform that
particular procedure on a child that age
so you may recall the this footage will
play again a little piece of this
exchange to uh refresh our memories here
it is
thank you for college national hospital
your call may be reported for quality
assurance i was calling uh for
information about gender affirming
hysterectomies
okay it's a gender forming history
i've been in touch with quite a few
hospitals and a lot of them well they
said they won't do it for for my 16 year
old
and then i was told that this hospital
might and i also saw it on your website
so if you guys do
do it for 16 year olds i'll i would be
happy for you know to come for a
consultation or whatever it takes let me
get you over to
the operator and i hate to transfer you
i just i just need to want to know if if
you guys do
service that age you know before
obviously
before coming you know coming all the
way for
an in-person consult and going through
all the paperwork yeah it depends each
department is different some some
departments cut off for 18. how old is
your patient 16.
okay all right so they're in the clear
well that was the first hospital
employee who unambiguously confirmed the
hospital will
rip the uterus out of a gender confused
child for a sizeable fee of course
shia was then transferred to a second
employee who once again confirmed it but
that's not the only confirmation she
received the hospital's own website
stated in no uncertain terms
that these hysterectomies are performed
on minors so to review that's two people
at the hospital and the website
all saying this
now if you just woke up from a
decade-long coma and were encountering
this story uh you'd be very confused and
horrified and probably wish that you
didn't wake up but you know you would
probably think that the scandal here the
massive earth-shattering scandal is that
a hospital by its own testimony is
cutting the reproductive organs out of
healthy young girls this is sadism and
brutality that would make joseph mengele
cringe
and yet it's happening right here in the
united states in our nation's capital
nonetheless
but if you've been awake and
semi-conscious at least for over the
last you know a few years you know that
the scandal is never the evil itself
that's never the scandal
but rather the fact that the evil was
exposed david deliden and the
center for medical progress learned this
the hard way when they went undercover a
few years ago to reveal planned
parenthood's business of selling the
body parts of aborted children
the media as you recall showed
absolutely no interest in the crimes
that were actually captured on tape
instead they focused all of their wrath
on the man who captured them
like all they cared about is is well not
what was revealed in the tape they want
to know how did you reveal it that's the
real story
a similar thing is happening now
the media circled the wagons around
children's national hospital just as it
had around boston children's which had
information on its website to go along
with a lengthy series of videos all
confirming that it performs various
gender affirming quote unquote
procedures on children
and once this was exposed that
information was scrubbed
you know from all the places the
websites and everything and the media
dutifully pretended that it never
existed
the same is the case here the washington
post
shortly after this recording was
released published a lengthy article
accusing
her of sending violent mobs after the
hospital and also accusing her of
misinformation for simply reporting what
the hospital itself explicitly said
wapo reports uh in their article
children's national hospital has been
inundated with threatening emails and
phone calls after an influential
right-wing twitter account published a
recording that falsely suggested that
the hospital's performing hysterectomies
on transgender children a hospital
spokeswoman said
the torrent of harassment was
accompanied by social media posts
suggesting that children's be bombed and
its doctors be placed in a wood chipper
the recording made by libs of tick tock
founder shia reichik features two
telephone operators at the renowned dc
medical facility stating in response to
rajic's questions that a 16 year old
trans boy would be eligible for
hysterectomy at the hospital's
development clinic gender development
clinic children's has not disputed the
authenticity of the recording but said
the employees provided inaccurate
inaccurate information
quote none of the people who were
secretly recorded by this activist group
deliver care to our patients hospital
spokeswoman ariana ahmadi perez said
we do not and have never performed
gender affirming hysterectomies for
anyone under the age of 18.
now once again
the spin from the hospital's public
relations department is being reported
as absolute fact as if it's
inconceivable that a pr department could
maybe lie or or you know
deflect
the washington post is not at all
curious about the fact that two hospital
employees and the website all said these
procedures are done
the hospital's allowed to rewrite
history out in the open and we're
supposed to pretend that you know we
don't notice
as for libs of tick tock the account was
summarily suspended from twitter for
quote unquote hateful conduct though no
offending tweet or specific rule
violation has been given now we're
accustomed to these kinds of
manipulations from big tech and the
media but that shouldn't prevent us from
approach from just appreciating how
egregious and evil this is
shia reichik has been branded a peddler
of misinformation and kicked off of a
major social media platform
simply for accurately reporting exactly
what a hospital said word for word
not even reporting it just
showing us letting us hear the recording
for ourselves
the system would probably prefer not to
be so blatant and out in the open
when it does this sort of thing but it
has decided that it has no choice
people are beginning to see just how
hideous and brutal and dangerous
the trans agenda is but they can't be
allowed to see it
the truth must be concealed no matter
the cost
and and whether we like it or not and i
certainly don't like it
is still the case
that children's hospitals are very much
a part of this conspiracy
children's hospitals across the country
are not only drugging and mutilating
kids that's a fact
but it's another fact they're conspiring
to conceal that from us now
how could you say this about children's
hospitals i don't know because it's
what's happening it's what they're doing
take this report from jason rantz last
week
reading out says a university of
washington study in partnership with
seattle children's hospital claimed that
gender affirming care via puberty
blockers leads to positive mental health
outcomes by for transgender teen
patients that characterization however
was false forcing substantial edits to
the materials used to promote the study
and prompting uw to cease promoting the
research
despite all that the uw communications
staff chose not to proactively respond
to quote some pretty concerning claims
about the study because it had already
received glowing media coverage
according to emails exclusively obtained
by jace the jason ranch show on ktth in
fact the uw medicine communications
staff never reached out to media outlets
that offered incorrect coverage based on
the faulty press materials
now worse than not reaching out they
actively covered up the truth
reading on here it says
fourth year uw medicine student aaron
collin and uw epidemiology phd candidate
diana tordoff tracked the mental health
of 104 transgender patients aged 13 to
20 for a year
the patients received gender affirming
care which the researcher defined as
taking either loop prolide uh
testosterone or estradiol using the data
collected from patient experiences the
research the researchers at uw medicine
claimed in a press release
that gender affirming care dramatically
reduces depression calling it
life-saving care the study was published
in jama open network in a march 11th
press release titled gender fermi care
dramatically reduces depression for
transgender teen study fines uw medicine
claimed that
researchers recently found that gender
affirming care for transgender and
non-binary adolescents cause rates of
depression to plummet
okay that's not what the study showed
the study actually showed no
improvements in mental health for the
patients receiving this form of care
no improvement
now be that as it may
the study while the version of the study
prepared for press releases received
lots of as i said glowing coverage
mainstream media was over the moon about
it finally we have a study confirming
what we've been claiming for years
finally
but it didn't exist
it was a lie
a journalist named jesse single
noticed some discrepancies between the
pr materials about the study and the
study itself and reached out to one of
the study's authors for more information
but the study's author stopped
responding once single asked to see the
actual raw data from the study that's
when they stopped didn't say anything
else
he contacted uw medicine and was
stonewalled there too
eventually he wrote a report detailing
his concerns which led to lots of
frantic scheming by officials at uw
medicine in seattle children's and we
know about that because now we have the
internal emails between those
institutions reading more from rance's
report it says internal emails between
uw medicine and seattle children's
acknowledge the seriousness of the
allegations it was so concerning that
laura east department of epidemiology
spokesperson
wrote in an email that she wouldn't
promote the study
quote the article resulting from the
inquiry was recently posted on the
author's sub stack and includes some
pretty concerning claims uw epidemiology
uw cpsph uw news will not be including
this article in our media tracking slash
or otherwise driving traffic to this
piece east email communication
colleagues at uw medicine and seattle
children's
now even after acknowledging all this
privately
that the claims were concerning and they
went on and there are more emails back
and forth
acknowledging that
you know it's
what what was what was claimed publicly
does not match up with what the study
actually says
and despite
them all agreeing to that privately the
decision was made between laura east and
other officials
not to publicly correct the record
this is an explicit agreement they made
in their emails back and forth we are
not going to reach out to the media and
tell them
that what they're saying about the study
is wrong
and they also said they're not going to
respond to any of the outlets that had
reached out to them and they felt
comfortable taking that position because
only conservative outlets had shown any
interest in getting to the truth about
the study now every other media outlet
took the study the pr version of it like
what was presented to them in the press
release and just put it in the headlines
and that was it they didn't even look
they didn't even look at the raw data
they just went with what they were told
by the pr departments
you're seeing a theme here emerge
whatever the pr department tells them
that's the story
no curiosity about what lies underneath
it
the only outlets that had any interest
in knowing about the actual information
were conservative outlets
and you can tell in the emails back and
forth between the you know pr
communications teams at the at these
hospitals
that they're very aware of that they're
very you know cognizant of the fact that
it's only conservative outlets that are
reaching out and so they feel
comfortable just ignoring them
now finally they did make corrections to
the study but they did so quietly
uh hoping nobody would notice
that it didn't matter anyway
they already got the headlines they
wanted and that's all that matters to
them
now the fact remains
that no credible long-term study
has ever confirmed the wild claims the
left makes about the benefits of gender
affirming care for kids
they have no studies to back them up
none
so they have to lie about the studies
they do have
but they also realize that this lack of
scientific evidentiary basis for what
they're doing to kids is a problem not a
moral problem as they see it as their
soulless demons who couldn't care less
about the morality of it but it's a pr
problem
which is why mark my words on this
eventually
they will simply fabricate an entire
study out of whole cloth eventually
we're going to hear about a long-term
study done over years with thousands of
patients that confirms beyond a shadow
of a doubt that uh that this is that you
know this
these procedures drugging and mutilating
kids is really good for them i mean we
already hear those claims then you look
at the study and you see that the claims
don't match up with us with what the
study actually says eventually they're
going to just make up a study
so that the so that the claims do match
up with what the study says
they will get the evidence they need one
way or another
and they know they can get away with
something like that
because the entire system has their back
and anyone who opposes or
exposes them
is simply shamed and silenced
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know some states have laws now that
have that say as early as the 2030 model
year new vehicles will have to be
electric in order to be registered cars
with internal combustion engines will
only be able to get license plates if
they were built before the end of the
2020s which means that people are going
to keep repairing and driving their old
cars for generations it also means you
better go to rockauto.com right now and
order all the parts to properly maintain
and repair your car your great grandkids
might be driving that car someday
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years family owned their
goal is to make auto parts available and
affordable to keep you safe on the road
rockauto.com is online parts catalog is
incredibly easy to use you can search
all the parts available for your
specific car
suv truck whatever you have with photos
specs and installation tips not only
will they have the part you need but
they're usually going to have several
trusted brands to choose from rock autos
kits are also popular because they
bundle together all the parts you need
for successful repair so go to
rockauto.com and get brakes shocks
carpets wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts or any other part you
need rockauto.com be sure to write walsh
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that i sent you
well we have to start here obviously
with the biggest news that the vmas were
last night nobody knows exactly why but
they happen they keep happening no one
can explain it nobody understands but
they keep on having the vmas and um all
i know is that lizzo was there my good
friend was obviously a big fan fan of
hers as you know first of all she
dazzled on the red carpet in this outfit
if we just take a look at this outfit
she's um
looking like there it is she looks like
a uh you know like a a giant trash bag
and i i say that not in a negative way i
mean it's a glam
here's what i'll say for this it's the
most glamorous trash bag i have ever
seen in my life hands down
either that or she looks like some sort
of sea creature like a
maybe ursula from a little mermaid
or maybe more like a
slightly misshapen lava cake
again i say all that
in as positive a way
as you possibly can
anyway she did win an award for
something and um she got up there and
she had a message she'd actually changed
her outfit maybe for the best
and uh but she had a message an
inspiring message and this was all over
social media last night people are very
inspired by this let's listen to it
i don't know
what uh music video for good means but i
do know what your vote means and that's
a
lot
your vote means everything
to me
it means everything to making a change
in this country
so remember when you're voting for your
favorite artist vote to change some of
these laws that are oppressing us
she's got something on her face there i
don't know if someone should probably
told her that before she went on i uh
okay i'm confused i'm actually confused
by a few things here i had
first of all she seems to indicate that
she won
for best music video for the song good
and but maybe but there is no music
video she said she doesn't know what
best music video for music she doesn't
know what music video for good means
which which leads me to believe
that she won best music video but it
doesn't the music video doesn't exist is
that am i
am i correct here
and then she goes on to say that well
when you're voting for your favorite
artist remember to vote to change the
laws
see
first do people vote for the vmas is
that is that does that is that open to
the public
i didn't think it was
but even if it is what relation does
that have to the laws so does she think
does she think that when you when you
vote for your who your favorite artist
is of the vmas that's that somehow that
has like some legal
that has some league has some kind of
legal impact
i don't know i'm i'm very much confused
by what she's saying there um
all i know is that what we got there at
the end is that we well we got to change
the laws that are oppressing us
so she's not sure how to change the law
she has no idea she thinks that by
voting for the vmas which i don't even
think you vote for uh you can change the
law she's confused about that
but all she knows is that there are laws
oppressing us
and of course when she says uh she
doesn't mean me
as a white guy she's not talking about
me she means her like laws that their
laws are oppressing her
but she can't she can't stipulate or
specify
what laws
she's talking about that are oppressing
her because and there's a reason for
that
because there are there are no laws at
all oppressing her
she is a member of several
different um privileged classes and so
there are no laws
oppressing her whatsoever
and in fact
even some of the laws that that
ostensibly apply to everyone and
restrict all of our behavior she gets to
effectively be exempt from
so there are no laws there's no
oppression whatsoever
but i do appreciate it all the same
because it's it's always a clarifying
moment and she's obviously not the first
one
but it's always a clarifying moment when
you get some wealthy celebrity at an
award show
wearing an outfit that costs more than
most people's cars
uh you know up at the awards show
talking about how they're oppressed
i'm oppressed
well if this is what oppression looks
like
to you then then words cannot describe
how blessed your life is
all right let's move to this uh report
from the daily wire brittany so we've
got
fake
heroism from a celebrity there
pretending to be heroic speaking out
against oppression but you can't but
there is no oppression not not there's
no pressure against her anyway there is
plenty of oppression in this country
it's just that she's exempt from almost
all of it
um that's the fake courage let's get to
some real courage from a celebrity uh
daily wire reports brittany aldean the
wife of country music star jason aldean
is fighting back after receiving attacks
from liberal country singers over an
instagram post criticizing the
transgender movement's focus on children
though most celebrities are reluctant to
express any sort of right-wing views
brittany 34 and her husband have become
increasingly vocal about being
conservative and supporters of former
president donald trump um she said i
really like to thank my parents for not
changing my gender when i went through
my tomboy phase
she said i love this girly life
and then that's what she originally
posted
um
and this is by the way a sentiment that
is very common you hear this people all
the time from adults especially from
women
because it's pretty common to go through
a you know so-called tomboy phase a
little bit more of a masculine
phase and um
i hear some women all the time like
thank god this stuff basically didn't
exist when i was a kid
because i would be chopped into pieces
right now they would have done it to me
too
so what she's expressing here is very
normal it's the kind of thing normal
people say all the time when they look
at the gender madness in our country
they look and they say well thank god
this didn't exist when i was a kid
but you know if you're in the public eye
you're not allowed to say normal things
especially not on this subject
and so uh there were a lot of
supportive comments but not from
other people in the country music world
um most of them just fell silent maybe
there's been a few countries i think
there's been a few country stars that
have come out in support of her but most
of them are just silent they're not
going to say anything about it and then
others have come out against her so
some in country music attacked britney
for the comments and called her names
the voice winner and country star
cassidy pope wrote via twitter
you'd think celebs with beauty brands
would see the positive in including
lgbtq plus people in their messaging but
instead here we are hearing someone
compare their tomboy phase to someone
wanting to transition
real nice
and there were more there's more
criticism like that but britney aldean
didn't back down posting a lengthy
response of her own online she says
advocating for the genital mutilation of
children under the disguise of love and
calling it gender affirming care is one
of the worst
evils she says i will always support my
children and do what i can to protect
their innocence
she says some parents want to be
accepted by society so badly that
they're willing to make life-altering
decisions for their children who aren't
old enough to fully comprehend the
consequences of those actions love is
protecting your child until they're
mature enough as an adult to make their
own life decisions thankful my parents
allowed me to go through my tomboy phase
without changing my gender until then
uh leave children alone
well obviously she couldn't be more
correct about all that
and
you think about where we are as a
society that it actually takes courage i
mean what is she saying in this post
all she's saying is
um don't chop the body parts off of
healthy children
don't drug and castrate them
and let them be kids
just let them live their lives as
children let them go through phases
and it's a normal thing
and yet a message like that actually
takes a significant amount of courage
for someone in her position to say
and so far she hasn't backed down
which is why it's important you know i
always um
the celebrities that that people with
with platforms who say something correct
and then they get it they get some
backlash and immediately back down i'm
always quick to
uh castigate those those cowards and
deservedly so
but the very few who say the correct and
truthful and right and important thing
but then stick by it i think we should
also support them and give them some
credit um and this is what we need we
need people in
the mainstream
to start speaking out against this
uh someone like me you know i'm i'm a
conservative commentator that's what i
am to most people
now i like to think there's some good
that can be done by me speaking out
against these things and i will continue
to do so
but i also realize that uh it just goes
with the territory do what i do for a
living that
the impact you can have is
you know you're somewhat handicapped
going into any kind of fight because uh
because you're well you're you're seen
as a political figure and so of course
you're going to talk about those things
so it's important for us to continue to
those of us who live in this world to
continue talking about it but what we
need are people who are not
seen primarily as political opinion
people to speak out
and they should be because we know that
almost everyone
almost everyone across the spectrum
looks at this kind of stuff they hear
about hospitals
who profess themselves that they do
gender affirming hysterectomies they
hear about that and almost everyone
knows that it is horrifying and insane
and one of the most frustrating things
and tragic things
and disgraceful things
is that if everyone
who who
recognized how horrifying this is all
the people who recognize it if they all
would just simply say so
if everyone would speak up everyone who
who knows the truth which is almost
everyone
if they would all simply say so
most of this stuff will go away
because at a certain point even though
the left owns all the systems in the
institutions at a certain point the
public pressure becomes too much
all right
axios has a report about another utopian
city of the future and i bring this up
for a reason which i'll get to in a
second but you remember the line in
saudi arabia that we talked about a
couple couple weeks ago that's a the the
utopian futuristic city concept where
everybody will live inside a giant wall
stretching through a desolate wasteland
because we know the libs like they don't
they want they don't want to build a
wall on the southern border but they
will build a wall and live inside it
so here's the new idea billionaire mark
lore is fleshing out his plan to build a
utopian city called telosa
for five million people in the american
desert and he's not the only one with
such ambitions there are about a dozen
projects worldwide to create sustainable
hyper-modern cities from scratch
while they may never come to fruition
the proposals themselves hint at what
cities of the future might look like
telosa is set to be built on 150 000
acres in either nevada utah arizona and
50 000 diverse people
is what they're saying diverse people
will call it home by 2030 according to
newly released details from laura serial
entrepreneur who sold jet.com to walmart
for 3.3 billion dollars
um and then the so there'll be a lot of
diverse people and it's going to be
sustainable and all these great things
be very futuristic whatever
i don't think you need all the details
here's the point
one of the many reasons why these
utopian city ideas don't work and can't
work because if you look at the pictures
from these you know the the the the
speculation about the artist
rendition of what this might look like
what do you always see these immaculate
cities
clean everything is peaceful everyone's
walking around smiling
and that's the problem right
yeah you could build an immaculate
peaceful clean city
if nobody lives in it
but once you start introducing people
then you have to take human nature into
account
um
and that's where things fall apart
because they even if they build these
futuristic wonderful cities
they're gonna put people in them and
then they're gonna run the cities just
like they run our current cities
not enforcing the law not doing anything
about homelessness uh you know people
are doing drugs laying all over the
street doing drugs and having overdoses
that's what it's going to become so
you're going to have a really nice
futuristic city that is just covered in
trash and filth and racked by crime
because they do not account for human
nature
one of the ways we know they don't
account for human nature aside from just
looking at the state of any city in the
country another way we know is um
because these are the same people coming
up with ideas like this in california
here's the latest idea
where they've decided they want to take
homeless people and move them into
hotels real simple solution right
because they look at homeless people and
they think well the problem here is that
the people don't have homes and so
we could solve the problem by just
putting them in a building
this is you know because this is how you
think if you're a leftist or if you're a
child
i can remember having this conversation
with my own kids when they were five
years old
and they would see homeless people and
say daddy
if they're homeless why don't we just
give them homes
and that's a very good question for a
five-year-old
but if you're an adult you should
realize that the homeless problem is not
prime you know it's it's not simply a
problem that they don't have homes
that's certainly not where the problem
begins like there's a reason why these
people don't have homes
um but tell that to the people that are
proposing this law let's uh watch a
little bit of the cnn report here
in los angeles county more than 60 000
people are homeless on the average night
and more than 20 000 hotel rooms lie
empty on the average night
see where this might be going it's it's
just it's insane
it it isn't going to solve the problem
we think this is one part of the
solution by no means do we think this
solves a homelessness crisis but do
hotels have a role to play of course
they do
so the union he leads which reps hotel
workers gathered enough signatures and
angelenos will vote on a bill that would
force every hotel in town to report
vacancies at 2pm every day
then
welcome homeless people into those
vacant rooms honestly would you check
into a hotel knowing that the chance of
your neighbor
to the left or right is a homeless
individual
manage patel voluntarily rents some
rooms to homeless people who are vetted
and paid for by a local church but he's
against this bill that would make that
mandatory we barely are surviving number
one number two
we have to think of the safety of our
staff and number three we're not
professionally or any otherwise equipped
with any of the supporting mechanism
that the homeless guest would require
what services would be provided remains
unclear also unclear the funding and
hotels would be paid fair market rate
brilliant just a brilliant idea can you
imagine you paid 900 a night to stay at
the ritz-carlton or something and
there's a homeless meth addict next door
like you're walking to your room they
wouldn't even say next door that assumes
they'd be in the room which they
wouldn't even be you're walking to your
room that you're paying hundreds and
hundreds of dollars for a night and
you're stepping over
a homeless guy defecating in the hallway
that's that's what they want to set up
and the great thing is one of the voices
of reason in this report is an actual
homeless guy who says uh no don't do
this
let's let's uh watch the rest of it
it's up to the city i mean they did it
during project room key the pandemic era
program now winding down that inspired
this bill by placing more than 10 000
people in hotels that volunteered sean
big deli among them well first of all
it's a blessing it's a it's a great room
the technology is not up to par but you
know what technologies you have in a
tent this bill would also force
developers to replace housing demolished
to make way for new hotels and hotel
permits would be introduced
as well as making every hotel from a
super 8 to the biltmore except homeless
people
as guests i don't think that's a good
idea why not maybe for some but you know
there's a lot of people with untreated
mental health and
some people do some damage to these poor
buildings man this happened in manage
patel's motel and she marked all walls
uh curtains she burnt thank god there
was no fire
even marked the ceiling opponents of
housing the homeless in hotels fear this
and
fear tourists could be put off from even
coming to l.a
yeah you think so i mean if they haven't
already been put off like i mean if
you're going to los angeles right now at
least
you might think that yeah the it's an
apocalyptic wasteland out there and
there's just homeless people and drug
addicts and criminals everywhere but but
at least i'll be safe inside the hotel
room you take that away and there's no
reason to go so you know what just just
let them do it
these idiots are they are determined
to just destroy their cities they are
determined to do it they want to destroy
their cities and live in the wreckage of
it and you know what go ahead and do it
you do something like this it is the end
of the hospitality and hotel industry in
the city and then thus it's the end of
the tourist industry as well because
those two things go hand in hand so i'll
go ahead and do it i mean why not go
ahead
you know what's the point of even
arguing against it
reasonable people trying to save you
maniacs from yourselves
but just for the record
this again is what if you're if you are
not a child if you're if you're over the
age of five my children you know my
nine-year-olds we had this conversation
when they were five they now understand
some things about about the homeless
problem that even adult leftists don't
understand
and one of the most one of the one of
the most fundamental things here
is that again there's a reason why
homeless people are homeless
because
you know
if everything else was normal
if these are just like normal
mentally healthy
people don't have drug abuse problems
there's no reason why they'd be homeless
okay if you don't have a drug abuse
problem
and you're not crazy
and especially if you're physically
you know
able
you can at least walk around
then there's no reason why you would end
up on the street for any length of time
because there's there's always some kind
of housing options might not be great
but you could get some kind of job and
afford some kind of house might not be
great might not be nice
okay it you know but but it you won't be
on the street
which is why
almost every homeless person you see on
the street
is
uh has severe mental health problems
okay
and or
is addicted to drugs
and for a lot of them it's both and the
two feed off of each other
you know when you're doing meth and
heroin and all that doesn't it's not
great for your brain
and so you could give them money you
could put them in the house but all but
they just it goes all right into the
drugs it's all they care about
and that's how they end up on the street
in the first place
so to just like leapfrog over the
underlying problems
mental illness drug abuse we're gonna
leap over that and just take these
people as they currently are and put
them in a in a in a house put them in a
room
there's zero chance that that results in
anything but total disaster
but whatever why even explain it go
ahead destroy your city go ahead and do
it please please do
have at it
all right one other thing a little bit
of entertainment news this is from
screen rant it says the terminal list
season two gets a hopeful update as lead
star chris pratt begins contract
negotiations negotiations debuting on
amazon prime video in july the action
thriller follows lieutenant commander
james reese and navy seal seeking to
avenge the murder of his family they'll
receive largely negative reviews the
term terminals made a big splash with
audiences landing the number one spot on
amazon prime's list within two weeks of
its premiere it also what was watched
for 1.6 billion minutes across its eight
episodes per nielsen's data
now i bring this up because my wife and
i just finished the terminal list this
weekend and i can report with confidence
that
among other things
the terminal list is yet another
argument for never taking critics
seriously ever about anything because
they have
as i mentioned in the article totally
panned the show
annihilated it it has like a 39 on
rotten tomatoes
abysmally bad ratings and which which is
absurd
because i watched it
and i discovered of course that it's a
very solid very effective show it's a
revenge thriller it's really dark i'm
warning you ahead of time you haven't
seen it it's brutal it does not
compromise um which i appreciate
i mean this is a show that doesn't pull
any punches at all like it doesn't take
you up to the brink and then pull back
it goes right over okay
but it's effective and it's suspenseful
and the performances especially chris
pratt's performance
um are terrific i think chris pratt's
performance in this is
his best work as an actor hands down
and to make the critical reaction even
more absurd there's another amazon show
um that's very similar in tone and plot
called reacher
about you know jack reacher which
tom cruise did the film version of this
character and then and then you know
most people think that the tv version is
much
closer to the um
to the source material but that show has
over 90 percent of rod tomatoes it's
also a revenge thriller it's also pretty
violent
the only difference is that terminal
list is better the performances are much
better uh it remains gripping from the
first moment to the last there's not a
lot of lag time it doesn't slow down
very much whereas reacher kind of drags
in the middle like most shows do so why
did terminals get panned it's because
well it stars chris pratt for one and
it's been decided
that chris pratt is some kind of
conservative christian which means that
you can never
favorably review anything that he stars
in anymore
um
even though that's not true he's not a
conservative christian but that's how
he's painted
and also the film is about badass tough
dudes that's what it's about
it doesn't compromise there either
it's it's about
you know tough violent men
they don't try to shoehorn any tough
kick-ass women into it there are women
in the film who play crucial roles in
the overall plot
but you don't see them
punching guys and knocking them out
nothing like that happens
and the show doesn't worry about filling
any diversity quotas either
although obviously there are non-white
people in the show you just don't get
the sense that they're in the show
for diversity reasons primarily they're
just there to tell the story and it's
the story that that matters
and that's why critics hate it
not a perfect show by any means there
are elements of it decisions that were
made especially towards the end that i'd
really care for but overall
very good show um
no show is perfect or few are anyway but
it's a good solid effective show worth
watching
and it's better at least than a show
featuring kim kardashian hillary clinton
and meghan the stallion and also gloria
steinem
which is what apple has coming out and
um this is a show play a little bit of
the of the preview for you
so terminalist has a 39
this show's gonna be we already know
that this is a 100
rave review before it even comes out we
don't even it doesn't need to come out
no one needs to see it
this is critically acclaimed
already from the beginning but here's
the preview
okay here we go
[Music]
we're hitting the road to shine a light
on women who inspire us to be bolder and
braver leadership doesn't look one way
it's a giant rainbow you're not gonna
break me down you'll get worn out before
i do women who push us outside our
comfort zone you got this and make us
laugh i'm in deep georgia and they might
have never met a muslim or they don't
know they have or they don't know they
have because we walk among you
do you have a marriage that has been on
public display since the beginning you
said the gutsiest thing you ever did was
stay in your marriage that doesn't mean
that's right for everybody
to throw someone's life away when people
really do make changes i just believe in
second chances my mother needed
rehabilitation not prison your survival
is your power
someone say to me you're not good enough
because you have melanin how dare you i
have a masters in whites i just want
places to get a ged in blacks
[Music]
every single person makes some impact on
the planet every single day
[Music]
we can choose what sort of difference we
make
speak truth to power
you know there's a a movie called uh
misery stephen king movie came out
you know years ago
uh with kathy bates
and she plays this insane sociopath who
takes this guy prisoner and at one point
she puts a a two by four between his
legs at the ankles and then takes a
sledgehammer and um
and hammers his feet so that they're
pointing at each other diagonally like
hobbling him so he can't go anywhere
and i bring that up because hillary
clinton reminds me a lot of kathy bates
in that film but also because i'd rather
have that happen to me
than watch one episode of that show
um
i don't want to see it as what i'm
trying to say it looks terrible
and it's not only a terrible show
but it continues to
cheapen the idea of courage which is
maybe the worst thing about because the
show is called gutsy
and then it's called gutsy we've got
hillary clinton
kim kardashian megan the stallion
few of these women have ever displayed
courage in their lives least of all
hillary clinton
um and then and then we're told in the
film the gutsiest moment of her life was
when she chose to stay with bill clinton
presumably after the lewinsky affair
but she also stayed with him after he
raped juanita broderick
allegedly
um and when he was accused of sexual
assault and harassment many other times
and when he was jet setting with jeffrey
epstein hanging out on sex slave island
she stayed through all of that didn't
just stay but she actually slandered and
silenced and intimidated her uh
rapist husband's accusers
and then had jeffrey epstein murdered
allegedly
so is that courage is that what that is
or is that being a heartless soulless
power hungry
demonic old witch
i mean tomato tomato i suppose
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
all right um melanie says thank you for
sharing the podcast statistics i'm in
california and feel lonely a lot
politically but knowing that only 12
shows from the daily wire ends up at
number six and the entire lineup really
does make me happy
let's go team
uh yeah well you're not alone you're
increasingly alone in california i do
have to tell you that so you might want
to think about if you can move but um
yeah across the country you're not alone
at all and as i said it's actually you
know 12 shows they counted us 12 active
shows and we're number i think six
overall in in downloads but
um only about half of those shows are
daily shows so really it's it's even
more impressive than that
if i do say so myself
bubble head says matt i hope you can
cover the issues regarding the va in
canada casually recommending euthanasia
to a veteran with p with ptsd
um that is an issue that i was totally
unaware of until i read this comment um
just right before it went on the air and
i did look into it briefly and yeah
i i don't know enough yet to give you a
full analysis of it other than to say
that that's obviously horrifying and
evil and wrong
um but that apparently is exactly what
happened there was a veteran that called
the va
suffering from ptsd
didn't have any terminal illness
although even if he did that still would
be horrifying and wrong to suggest that
he killed himself but but didn't he's
like struggling right mentally and
emotionally with
uh trauma related to to combat and
everything else
and it was suggested casually by the
person on the phone oh well you might
you might think about killing yourself
now there wasn't
maybe it wasn't put that way exactly but
that's what was said
and that is um something that already
happens in other parts of the world in
other parts of europe they they you know
euthanasia is somewhat common
for people who do not suffer from
terminal illnesses
and we're gonna start to see that more
and more on this side of the atlantic
and i've been warning about that
this is one of the reasons why we should
oppose euthanasia across the board
period
because hopefully everyone sees by now
when it comes to the left and it comes
to their anti-human death cult agenda
when you open the door to them even a
crack
right
then you've let them in
you cannot open the door even a crack
you got to keep that door shut
and the problem is that all of these
doors to all of these terrible things
we've opened all the doors
and then we've opened them a little bit
and said oh this is as far as we want to
open it it's too late now
so with euthanasia with the idea of like
doctors killing somebody as a form of
medical treatment
that is a door we should have kept shut
but we didn't
um
the 20b the 20 bandit one says i'm
loving this season of matt walsh the
giant walrus plot is epic
is it i feel like we're stretching it a
bit i feel like that plot is a little
bit stretched i don't know that's just
that's just me
um not that it's not important it is
very important don't get me wrong lior
says can we please be told uh what it is
we're missing out on on the members only
section maybe it's when matt gets all
cheery and soft-hearted and starts
talking about his hidden admiration and
love for pandas we won't tell you this
is for and i made it clear with the with
the daily wire members
that they're my favorites
and the conversations that we have are
just between us
okay so if you want to be
in that club
you have to sign up
um ty my shoe says we need matt on uh
matt on rogan well
i agree i'd love to go on joe rogan
maybe reach out to joe rogan and uh and
suggest it if you're a fan of his show
as as am i i know he's a big he's a big
fan of the film what is a woman talks
about it all the time which i really
appreciate love to go on and
talk about the film with him hint
let's get to the daily cancellation
[Music]
you know when i was a kid many years ago
it was a thought that the left who we
perhaps erroneously called liberals at
the time
mainly wanted to break down boundaries
and establish a free less rigid more
open society
now i didn't think that about the left
even when i was like eight years old i
knew better but lots of people did think
it in recent years however even the most
naive and oblivious among us have
finally begun to understand the truth
leftists on the whole are not only
uninterested in freedom and openness but
are in fact primarily focused on
establishing boundaries that's their
main thing this is the defining
characteristic
of the modern leftist he wants more
rules
more ordinances and mandates more
fencing to contain and control people
it's just that the boundaries he seeks
to set
are arbitrary and capricious and often
psychotically petty
and he himself is always of course
exempt from them
just the last few days have given us a
couple of examples of this sort of thing
we start here in modesto california a
quote straight pride march
quote devolved into violence as the new
york post puts it in their report when
counter protesters clashed with the
marchers outside of abortion clinic now
it's generally agreed by the media and
by the counter protesters who showed up
at the march and seemingly by most
people on social media
that a straight pride march is not only
absurd but also inherently bigoted
and yet the very same people who will
categorize a straight pride march in
that way
will also insist that gay pride marches
are noble and important
so here we see the arbitrary boundary
being put in place
gays can march you know and they should
be celebrated for doing so heterosexuals
who march are bigots and morons
that's the boundary
but it makes no sense
there is no intelligible reason
that anyone's ever given or could ever
give why it's acceptable to march and
express your pride in every sexual
orientation under the sun
except heterosexuality
just as there is no intelligible
coherent reason why it should be
considered good and healthy for every
race and ethnicity to express pride in
themselves and their heritage except
white people
the left has attempted to build this
fortress around the concept of pride and
declared that no white straight people
should ever be allowed inside yet they
can't really justify that
everyone everywhere
um is allowed to be proud of who they
are the left says except white straight
people they're the only ones who can't
in fact for them
such pride is it's unthinkably brutally
racist and bigoted
and this is the rule they've established
and for whatever reason most people are
happy to follow it without asking any
questions about it
now in reality
i think it's ludicrous for anyone to
take pride in their sexual orientation
being attracted a certain way is not in
itself an achievement
now i take pride in my beautiful wife
and my children my family
none of which i would have if i wasn't
heterosexual
but
it it would feel rather reductive and
silly to call my pride and my family
straight pride actually rather than a
straight pride march i'd be in favor of
a family march how about that
perhaps we should have a a march
celebrating the family
celebrating the nuclear family that's
what the march should be
they'll call it a straight pride march
called a family pride march
not a bad idea the more think about it
in any case the point is that however
silly a straight pride march might be it
cannot possibly be any sillier than a
gay pride march
and that i'm guessing is the primary
point that the people in the straight
pride march are trying to make you don't
get to make rules for us you don't get
to grant yourself special privileges it
doesn't work that way
if you get to march then so do we
that's the point it's perfectly valid
the left's boundaries that they set up
should be broken down just simply for
the sake of breaking them down
and this is especially true as the
boundaries become more bizarre and
constricting and trivial
which brings us to our second example
there's a tick tock user who goes by the
handle a mushroom blackly
and she went viral over the last few
days with her reaction
to a drew barrymore video
where barrymore runs laughing through
the rain
now a mushroom blackly has decided that
uh it's racist for a white person to
frolic in the rain
so that's why she now i can think of
many reasons to oppose adults doing any
kind of frolicking at all but she's
making it racial and she's saying that
the problem is that if you do this then
you're racist against black people
though she's not really able to explain
why let's uh listen
you and i both know
that you are capable
of enjoying the rain
and frolicking freely without filming it
and then posting it to tick tock
now you've just cosigned
okay you just co-signed at least 3
million 8.5 by 11 front and back
people who just go out of their way
to disrespect and dismiss the boundaries
that black creators have set
and now you're one of those people
so
i guess my question would be
why
why why is it so important to all of you
to treat us like
we don't matter
now it's hard to know
exactly where to begin here she makes
clear that black tick tock creators have
set a boundary
which forbids white people from publicly
enjoying themselves in the rain
we may do so privately perhaps in our
own backyards where no one can see us
but we may not make a spectacle of this
enjoyment
and if we do
then we're not only racist but we're
sending a message that black people
don't matter
so you watch that video of drew
barrymore
laughing in the rain
what she's she's laughing about the fact
she she's she's like this is like an
evil laughter she's laughing about how
much she hates black people
apparently
yet it's not explained why this is
racist or how frolicking in the rain
could send a message like that or why
these boundaries were set were set or
perhaps more importantly why anyone
should give the slightest damn about the
boundaries she has set up for us
now fortunately she did post a follow-up
video with more information so maybe
we'll get a little bit more clarity here
why is it
an issue for me to stand firm in what i
believe
male black craters frolicked in the
grass female black creators started
frolicking in the rain
okay oh poor drew had a hard childhood
says the white woman to the black woman
in america i'm not picking nobody is
picking on her i pointed out the obvious
but
what y'all really are not catching
is
the reactions
like okay say that was a complete and
total stretch right
y'all still went out of your way to
demean me put me down call me out my
name
dismiss my opinion on my own tick tock
but defend drew in her hard childhood
because she's the only one who ever had
a hard childhood
we went out of our way to dismiss your
opinion and demean you because you're
stupid that's why
it's a perfectly logical response
but but it all makes sense now uh well
it doesn't make sense but at least now i
understand what sort of nonsense we're
dealing with
a mushroom blackly believes
that white people cannot engage in any
form of frolicking not just frolicking
in the rain but even frolicking in the
grasses out of bounds
because
black people on tick-tock frolicked
before us apparently there are black
people on tick tock frolicking this is a
thing i guess and but they invented it
and having invented it nobody with
lighter skin is allowed to engage in it
therefore
so what drew barrymore has done here is
a form of frolic based plagiarism
this is the claim it and it is of course
mind-numbingly stupid
though i actually appreciate it in a
certain way because mushroom blackly has
inadvertently illustrated the absurdity
of the appropriation charge now this
might be the most absurd version of of
appropriation but it kind of shows it
it's symptomatic of of pretty much all
appropriation claims
because obviously
black people did not invent frolicking
they weren't the first ones to do it in
general nor to film it
and even if they did which they didn't
that still would not give a certain race
ownership over the practice of
frolicking frolicking is open to all
races i myself frolic through fields of
daffodils on a weekly basis and will
continue to do so it's how i get my
cardio
but this is how the appropriation claim
usually works a white person is accused
of stealing something that first of all
was absolutely not invented by the race
they're accused of stealing it from and
second of all cannot be stolen anyway
because it cannot be possessed in the
first place
but this is almost beside the point
the boundaries are not meant to be
logical or defensible or morally
coherent they exist simply to be abided
by
the left erects these fences and walls
and the rest of us are meant to just
live within them
as the boundaries get closer and closer
together and more and more things become
suddenly off limits and more and more
things that you enjoy doing and i enjoy
doing like frolicking all of a sudden
you're not allowed to do anymore it's a
game of power and control
and the only way to win the game
is to refuse to play it
so
march for straight pride if you want
frolic in the rain
you can even
frolic for straight pride
though that may send
mixed messages
do whatever you want
because the people who set these
arbitrary ridiculous boundaries are
today canceled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you over there if i
don't see you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you